despite efforts to curb climate change
carbon dioxide emissions have continued
to rise over the past
10 years countries and companies
urgently need to mobilize for a greener
future
companies are going to have to make the
distinction between trying to look good
and actually having impact promises are
easy to make
delivering on them is more difficult
[Music]
zany minton bedos our editor-in-chief
spoke with bill gates
about what needs to be done to fund the
green economy
let's start with how this year how covid
has affected your thinking on the
climate i think in a recent
blog post you wrote covid19 is awful
climate change could be worse
so what does this year taught us about
how we need to approach the climate
crisis well climate is
is like the pandemic in that we really
count on governments
to think about the future to bring in
experts
and avoid terrible things happening out
in the future
in the case of the pandemic it wasn't
taken seriously
there wasn't much preparation and so now
we're paying the huge consequence
there is a difference though which is
that the pandemic
uh over a period of years we can
innovate come up with a vaccine in
particular
and bring it to an end climate is
something that's
slowly getting worse and worse and
there's nothing
uh anywhere near to a vaccine
you know where for tens of billions of
dollars
you invent it manufacture it get it out
to people and the problem goes away
here climate change is a side effect
of the entire physical economy
so it's not as easily solved it's it's
it's coming it's inevitable
how do you frame the climate challenge
and particularly is it
primarily a challenge of behavioral
change that we need to change the way we
live to be more sustainable
or is it a challenge of innovation that
we need to find new technologies
that allow us to live in a in a carbon
neutral way
we're not just trying to reduce
emissions by 15
or 20 percent uh we're trying to get to
zero
and since the kind of activities
that create greenhouse gases today are
pervasive
you cannot drive the demand for those
services
down all that dramatically in fact in
developing countries you should allow
the demand for those services to go up
and so it
although it always helps every little
bit helps
you can't get anywhere near zero without
having a new way of making steel
or propelling a passenger car
or a plane it it requires an innovation
where the extra cost of doing it the
clean way which i call the green premium
through innovation is brought down
ideally to zero
but if not to such a small level
that you know say india would
choose as they build those buildings and
add that
electricity capacity uh that they would
do it
the the greenway so we'll get to how to
bring that green premium as you call it
down in a second but let's start with
the innovation that's needed itself and
and particularly in two dimensions let's
start firstly with
what are the renewable technologies
right now that you think are the most
promising that need to be scaled up
well it's phenomenal that
the cost of wind both on turn offshore
has gone down a lot
uh it's phenomenal that lithium
batteries
uh that allow passenger cars to get
reasonable range
that the premium and cost of electric
cars
isn't gigantic today and will come down
over time and then solar cells
which have come down in cost more
rapidly than almost anyone predicted so
those three things are good
uh sadly there are many things that
those don't solve
like making steel or cement or flying a
plane
we just don't have a clue uh of how to
make those in a completely green fashion
so those are areas where we don't even
have the technology to make the products
in a green way so we have to have that
innovation and then
as you say we have to bring the price
down the green premium as you call it
such that they'll be used
let's talk about how we get there um and
in particular what is the role of the
private sector
you know what do you think is it's one
thing having philanthropic money but
you're going to need
large amounts of capital mobilized to do
this so how how do you get there
yeah so for each technology
you have to say where is it uh and as we
discussed
the solar wind uh
and the lithium batteries are fairly
mature and and so
just a little bit of tax incentives
are driving those things forward that's
that is a good thing
the technologies like making green steel
are still very much at an r d stage and
so you want
uh at the beginning of this pipeline to
raise the research budgets of
the rich countries to work in these
areas
you know then at the next stage you want
to raise the
uh risk oriented capital
either inside a big company or in a
startup
to go and do this work but here when
you're building these big
steel plants you're coming up with a
product that's not differentiated green
steel
sadly uh has no uh
benefits beyond its its greenness you
know who wants to be the first
to put green steel in their building why
should you
you know take a risk that maybe it's
slightly
uh inferior in some way and so
we we can use our we can look at venture
funding
but we need uh the scale of capital
and the the persistence is going to be
more difficult
presumably one way of getting that is to
change the regulatory environment to
change incentives so i guess one
question is
how essential is at a governmental level
you know a carbon tax or something that
prices carbon to create the right
incentives
yes absolutely a carbon tax if it's
politically adoptable if that can
practically happen
a carbon tax at quite a high level
that you know has some resemblance
to the green premiums for these products
so it would have to be like a hundred to
two hundred dollars a ton
that sends out the clear uh market
signal
now sadly you know when people put like
france
you know put a bit of a tax on diesel
fuel or when the u.s politicians talk
about carbon taxes
the chance that we'll get a that
sort of straightforward clear uh
policy i don't think is very likely and
so we do have to
be creative and say okay if you don't
have that
uh let's look at some of the individual
sectors and let's look at the companies
who make a lot of money and uh let's
look at the government's own use of
these products
and somehow perform the bootstrap
without that i mean microsoft has
adopted the goal of reducing its total
emissions including
historical ones i think to net zero
should that be a goal for all companies
well we we expect leadership from
companies that are big
and profitable and doing well
and you know have the iq to have a
department that's really thinking these
things through and the technology
companies
through their data center or pc products
directly and indirectly they're
responsible for
a measurable amount of emissions but yes
these companies
uh they want to solve these problems
their employees want to solve these
problems
and it's the metrics about uh you know
just buying
what's called the renewable energy
credit or wreck you know has allowed
people to say oh we just used the green
electrons the standards for
being able to say that you're green will
be raised
companies are going to have to make a
distinction between
trying to look good uh and actually
having impact and
you know are they participating in
getting beyond
the renewable energy credit thing uh
are they participating in getting if
they're
you know are they really starting to
have an internal carbon price
are they taking the money from that and
putting it into activities
that will make a difference you know
just reporting yes that's a good thing
but you know a steel company is going to
report a large number
an electricity utility that's providing
a reliable electricity
is going to put a large number that
doesn't mean
that oh let's not finance them anymore
nobody should work there
you know these services are very very
important
there's a reason we haven't made
gasoline illegal and
what about the us you know still the
world's largest economy the one who's
whose federal policy shall we say has
has kind of bucked the trend thus far
uh can the world really make progress
without serious progress in the u.s
basically no uh in two dimensions the
u.s
has got to be an exemplar we have to
uh move our consumption even
paying green premiums to get the volume
for those products
to get scale which drives the green
premium down so the us has to be
a buyer uh as of those things including
in the hard categories
you know i can't emphasize enough the
over focus on the easy stuff i've never
seen a domain
that in all the meetings are about hey
electric cars oh this problem solved
come on tell me about steel come on
department of energy
it hardly even thinks about steel
because they're about energy that
they aren't the department of steel
making or the industrial processes
and you know show me you know tell me
what the green premium for steel
is who is the best uh in class right now
you'd have to go
buy direct air capture is is would be
your only way of saying
you know which i as an individual want
to across all my things so i'm going to
buy
individually director capture to offset
the you know it's not
that gigantic amount of steel that i'm
i'm connected to
so the us uh without the us
this you'll never meet anything like a
2050 goal you won't be at a 2060 goal
because our innovation power for the
entire world
and our missions and leading by example
is certainly a necessary but not
sufficient part of this movement
so if you had a us president who was
serious about doing this
and you know joe biden says he wants to
spend two trillion dollars decarbonizing
the us economy
where should he start
well the key thing is innovation
you know i i'm sort of a one trick pony
in terms of
what i understand that 2 trillion a
fairly
modest part of it needs to be devoted
to driving markets uh
to buy at the current green premium and
get that volume
learning curve going we have to fund
basic r d
we have to encourage risk taking capital
and we have to create
a demand side signal for
the lowest premium products so that over
time
their prices do what uh solar cells uh
did and and so yes i
i'm very excited that he wants to put a
lot of resources into this
and helping to be part of that dialogue
to make sure that money's well spent
uh you know i i'd look forward to that
opportunity
so your message that innovation is the
key has come through loud and clear
what about your assessment of the odds
of success i guess to end this
conversation where we started it
has the pandemic and the experience of
this year
raised your assessment of those odds so
far i'd say
you know it looks like people are going
to keep in mind
that the need to invest and invent for
this long-term problem even though often
when you have short-term problems
you you ignore those long-term things so
i'm amazed
that the advocates here have said okay
you know
what's the lesson from this and so that
recovery fund thing or the fact that you
know
biden doesn't feel that he has to uh
get rid of his climate focus
uh to help recover that he feels both of
those things can be done so so far i'd
say
uh it it looks looks more positive than
negative
well that seems a suitably upbeat place
to end thank you bill as always
fascinating all right
thanks bill gates was talking to us for
the economist event sustainability week
in october
part of a series of global events aiming
to accelerate action against climate
change
to register for sustainability week 2021
or to find out more about future events
on climate change click on the link
thanks for watching
you